ryan reynolds is an actor with a resume
full of hits and misses
he's not afraid to take on the silliest
of roles and sometimes he even pokes fun
at his biggest mistakes
he might be a superstar but simply
attaching his name to a project doesn't
guarantee it's going to be a success you
shut your
damn trash mouth not every film reynolds
releases is going to be deadpool
no matter how big the budget or how
great the supporting cast is
sometimes an actor will have a failure
on their hands that's the case with one
of reynold's biggest movies of the last
few years
it was one we were confident would get a
sequel at first however
we just learned there are no franchise
plans for this popular netflix original
in 2019 netflix released six underground
a high octane action flick with ryan
reynolds as the lead and michael bay
directing on a 150 million dollar budget
the film was full of pulse-pounding
action sequences and dramatic explosions
in a promotional video reynolds called
it the most michael bay movie that
michael bay has ever michael bade
the action comedy flick centers around a
billionaire known as
one played by reynolds he fakes his
death to create a vigilante crew that
takes down terrorists
and other scummy criminals the team
includes five other members who are
named
two three four five and six creative
right
the film sounded good on paper but when
it finally landed on netflix in december
of 2019
it was ripped to shreds by reviewers it
currently holds a 38
critic score on rotten tomatoes so it's
not suicide squad level bad
but still pretty terrible the problem it
was overstuffed silly and a little
too michael bay robert levin of newsday
described the film perfectly
saying this is a terrible action movie
that utilizes michael bay's worst
instincts and
none of his best despite being one of
netflix's most viewed original movies of
all time
six underground was a miss in every
other way it was so bad that netflix's
film chief scott stuber told variety a
sequel
definitely isn't coming the netflix boss
admitted
we didn't feel like we got there on that
one creatively it was a nice hit but at
the end of the day we didn't feel like
we nailed the mark to justify coming
back again
there just wasn't that deep love for
those characters or that world
netflix never confirmed a sequel for the
movie but it was largely suspected based
on its high viewership
going off of stuber's recent comments
however it looks like numbers aren't the
only important thing
not only does a netflix original need to
attract a large audience but it also
needs to resonate with those viewers
six underground just didn't have people
talking at the water cooler and the ones
who were weren't talking about it in a
good way
netflix is choosing to move forward with
sequels for debut films that had a
positive response
both quantitatively and qualitatively in
the action genre that catalog
includes the old guard and extraction
just to name a few
so ryan reynolds and company won't be
reuniting for six underground two
seven underground or two underground too
furious
but with plenty of other films on his
docket he's probably not too worried
about it at this point
scott stuber further expressed what is
of utmost importance to the folks at
netflix when it comes to making original
content
we have to be more consistent at making
these movies more culturally relevant
and putting them in the zeitgeist
we know the audience is there for these
movies but i want people to feel that
impact in their conversations with
friends and colleagues
where they're saying did you hear about
this movie old guard we've done it but
we haven't done it consistently
it all comes back to those water cooler
moments which yes is twitter these days
and unfortunately for six underground it
trended for all the wrong reasons
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you